[Música]
y
semana de diferentes acontecimientos en
torno a la guerra en ucrania la semana
comenzó con la visita de la presidenta
de la comisión europea úrsula von der
leyen quien estuvo en kiev para reunirse
con el presidente ucraniano volodymyr
zielinski el encuentro sirvió para dar
un poco más de luces sobre esa
aspiración de ucrania para ser parte de
la unión europea qué tan factible puede
ser esto lo vamos a analizar en unos
minutos con nuestros invitados esta
visita precisamente también estuvo
reforzada por la visita del canciller
alemán olaf scholz y de la visita del
presidente francés emmanuel majo quien
también visitó bucarest y kiss in out
para mostrar su apoyo a rumanía y
amoldar ya que son países que han
recibido a miles de refugiados que han
huido de la guerra en ucrania más
detalles en el siguiente informe veamos
un estrechón de manos como muestra la
unidad y solidaridad de europa con
ucrania el presidente ucraniano
volodymyr selenski recibió al presidente
francés de manuel marcó al considere
alemán olaf scholz al primer ministro
italiano mario draghi y al presidente
rumano klaus johannis los líderes
afirmaron su voluntad de ver a ucrania
como candidato inmediato oficial de la
unión europea selenski insistió en la
importancia de este camino y se dijo
dispuesto a trabajar con el objetivo de
la membresía y estamos listos para
trabajar en nuestro estado para
convertirnos en un miembro pleno de la
unión europea los ucranianos ya se han
ganado el derecho para seguir este
camino y obtener ese estatus de
candidatos es candidato previo al
encuentro los líderes visitaron los
suburbios de kiev escenario de las
primeras etapas del conflicto desde jim
mccann dijo ver señales de crímenes de
guerra y afirma que francia seguirá
participando en su investigación que
existía y usted está aquí en irvine en
un sitio que ha sido destruido donde
junto con varias otras ciudades el
ejército ruso fue efectivamente detenido
donde se llevaron a cabo sacrest tenemos
las primeras señales de que éstos habían
sido crímenes de guerra
emanuel makoun también anunció el envío
de más armas a ucrania incluyendo otros
seis cañones propulsado césar un apoyo
militar previamente criticado pero
también minimizado por el kremlin
esperamos que no sólo se concentren en
discutir el apoyo a ucrania en términos
de suministro de armas es absolutamente
inútil sólo prolongará el sufrimiento de
las personas y dañará aún más al país
pero los dirigentes europeos aclamaron
el heroísmo de los ucranianos y los
invitaron a resistir para ganar la
guerra se comprometieron con el apoyo a
ucrania por el tiempo que sea necesario
también fue destacado esta semana ya lo
veíamos en el reporte ese apoyo de mil
millones de dólares por parte de eeuu a
ucrania una partida que se suma a otros
40.000 millones de dólares ya donados
por washington el pasado mes de mayo
mientras tanto en el terreno allí siguen
los intensos combates y los bombardeos
sobre todo en la ciudad de severá
donestsk y en la vecina ciudad de lis y
sanz en donde ya ha habido
complicaciones para poder evacuar a los
civiles tanto ucranianos se han acusado
mutuamente de entorpecer la salida de
los pocos ciudadanos que aún quedan allí
veamos
un mensaje de agradecimiento de
volodymyr selenski el miércoles por la
noche después de haber recibido una
ayuda desesperadamente necesario el
estado de los eeuu han anunciado un
nuevo refuerzo de nuestra defensa un
nuevo paquete de ayuda de mil millones
de dólares esto incluye la defensa
costera la artillería y los modernos
sistemas de misiles agradezco este apoyo
es especialmente importante para nuestra
defensa en el tomba no sólo de bobo como
produce zinc la nación borón landon más
mientras tanto los combates en la región
del tumbas se intensifican considerado
nets como punto central de la guerra en
un escenario similar al de mariupol
varios cientos de civiles y un número
desconocido de combatientes permanecen
atrapados en la planta química al sur de
la ciudad los funcionarios regionales
afirman que el panorama está empeorando
con el ejército ruso rodeando a los
soldados ucranianos por tres frentes
pero a pesar de que la presión aumenta
quien ignoró el miércoles un ultimátum
de moscú para entregar la urbe en otro
lugar de la región del donbass al menos
dos personas resultaron heridas en la
ciudad de wukro después de que un cohete
impactar a una zona residencial
estábamos haciendo nuestras tareas en
casa entonces hubo un estallido y todos
nos caímos al suelo había mucho polvo y
humo ya no hay casa
[Música]
mientras tanto las evacuaciones han
continuado en el oeste del país con
muchos residentes indefensos huyendo de
sus hogares en la ciudad de europea casi
intacta y elena estaba durmiendo en su
cama cuando una explosión hizo volar el
techo de su casa fue uno de los varios
golpes que se produjeron a lo largo del
día pero a pesar del creciente peligro
ella ha decidido quedarse y
hay bombardeos por toda ucrania donde
vamos a ir tiene sentido irse si
llegamos a algún sitio qué pasa si hay
otro ataque nos quedaremos en esta
ciudad muy un tour
en su última previsión ucrania dice que
rusia está planeando extender los
ataques por todo el donbass en los
próximos días apuntando a estudiantes
desde el norte y aún 30 cerca debajo
hacia el sur desde rusia la compañía
gazprom anunció una reducción en el
envío de gas a europa de otra parte el
canciller de la federación sérguei
lávrov en una entrevista concedida a la
bbc negó que rusia hubiera invadido a
ucrania acusó a occidente de emitir
noticias falsas en los diferentes medios
de comunicación y también dijo que la
operación militar especial era necesaria
dado que no había otra forma de que
occidente comprendiera que incorporar a
ucrania a la otan era una acción
criminal según sus palabras que pasara o
que pensara entonces de una posible
incorporación de ucrania a la unión
europea lo vamos a analizar en este
episodio del debate a ucrania candidata
a la unión europea de nuestro tema de
análisis para este episodio y para
conversar sobre este tema saludamos a
ruth ferrero ella es docente de ciencias
políticas y estudios europeos en la
universidad complutense de madrid
es investigadora adscrita al instituto
de estudios internacionales y aquí en el
estudio de france 24 nos acompaña a
jesus agreda él es internacionalista
también es docente de la pontificia
universidad javeriana que está ubicada
en la ciudad de bogotá en colombia
ustedes nuestros televidentes también
hacen parte de esta conversación dejen
todos sus comentarios a través de las
redes sociales estamos en facebook en
instagram en twitter y también pueden
ver nuestra señal en streaming a través
de youtube nos encuentran como france24
guión bajo s arroba santi logo que es mi
cuenta personal esperamos sus
comentarios con la etiqueta numeral el
debate efe 24 participen en este
programa comienza entonces dándole la
bienvenida root en españa' ruth gracias
por acompañarnos por estar con nosotros
en el programa y quiero conocer sus
impresiones como punto de partida a este
gran resumen de los hechos de la semana
las visitas de estos representantes de
la unión europea de diferentes
presidentes y cancilleres y delegados y
esa ayuda de eeuu y también la situación
que se está viviendo en zeberio nietos
que desde hace varias semanas viene
siendo el foco de los ataques de las
tropas rusas
bueno lo que estamos viendo en el frente
es bueno estaban en el donbass que ya
comenzó hasta hace unas cuantas semanas
vienen donde se concentra la el ataque
el ataque ruso y en relación con en
relación con
con la visita de los líderes italianos
francés y alemán y el rumano también a
que yo creo que es una visita
extremadamente importante desde el punto
de vista de la política simbólica de la
unión europea y recordemos el anís el
sistema cronometraje habían visitado
y de hecho se había dicho que
solamente diría 10 no para hacer la foto
sino para
debatir y hablar de cuestiones que
esperan fundamentales y efectivamente
estamos a una semana
en debate que se va a abrir en el seno
de los dos miembros a través del cual
bueno pues tendremos que el cual son las
posiciones en relación con que se pueda
abrir ese
estatus de candidato para ucrania en
potencia el ingreso en la unión europea
sería abandonar definitivamente el
partenariado oriental para pasar a la
parte de la política europea de
ampliación y
veremos si esto es esto es factible o no
sí pero ya vaya ya lo hemos ya lo iremos
viendo en las próximas días ya lo vamos
a analizar en profundidad en este
programa rotc no se me adelanté que eso
es parte de los temas que tengo en la
agenda le doy la bienvenida aquí en el
estudio jesús agrede a jesús gracias por
acompañarnos aquí en el estudio en
france24 y su perspectiva sobre estos
temas de la semana impresiones que se
destaca que puedas resaltar el primero
muchas gracias por limitación es un
gusto estar aquí y la verdad es que sí
han habido muchos cambios han habido
algunas conciencias son poco extrañas
que ya aclare pero sí digamos lo que
ruth ha hecho es muy cierto primero
comenzando con las visitas es una visita
muy simbólica que demuestra un
compromiso que se había expresado con él
sobre todo digamos en el caso de
alemania han habido muchos
cuestionamientos de ucrania sobre qué
tan comprometido estaba realmente
alemania con el apoyo y esta visita
demuestra digamos ese compromiso
demuestra el compromiso la unión europea
la digamos un poco la solidez
de la unión europea como como actor
frente al ciber daniels efectivamente
digamos es el centro del conflicto
pero no significa que sea el último no
decir efectivamente las declaraciones de
los líderes de danny as de la república
popular de un jet indicarían que digamos
el objetivo no es sólo consolidar toda
la región de lugansk sino también es
consolidar toda la región de tenias e
incluso ir más allá digamos en esa
agresión militar así que digamos es un
punto importante pero no es el fin de la
guerra aún como se podría pensar claro
son episodios que se van abriendo
cerrando conforme van avanzando los días
quiero enfocarme en este momento en ese
proceso de incorporación de ucrania que
es tal vez lo más destacado de la semana
ese acercamiento esa muestra de apoyo
por parte de bruselas y los diferentes
líderes europeos
ruth que tan factible es que ucrania
tenga una adhesión o una incorporación o
un estatus particular
a través de un proceso digamos express
para poder entrar a la unión europea y
eso como cambiaría entonces el juego de
la guerra porque teniendo un estatus
avalado por bruselas moscú podría tomar
una posición diferente
bueno habría que ver qué tipo de estatus
qué tipo de relación y sobre todo si hay
acuerdo o no en esa relación especial
con ucrania en el seno del consejo
europeo
yo creo que un procedimiento expresa
acelerado de delante entradas están en
la unión europea' cuestionaría todo el
proyecto europeo desde su raíz
tendría que haber una reforma profunda
de los tratados abrir un proceso de
reforma a través de una convención y eso
lleva mucho tiempo
pensemos que los países de los balcanes
llevan esperando muchos años son países
que si los comparamos con ucrania son
mucho más pequeños y por lo tanto no
tendrían que generar tantos problemas
institucionales como una potencia la
adhesión de ucrania que spies
extremadamente grande con una gran carga
demográfica en torno a 44 millones lo
cual en él en términos de por ejemplo de
procesos de toma de decisiones el marco
del post europeo generaría muchísimos
desequilibrios por tanto yo creo que
este momento
esta esta este cambio digamos de la
unión europea que abre una una suerte de
perspectiva europea se plantea
incorporar a ucrania dentro del marco de
la política exterior en la política de
ampliación de la unión europea y sacarla
del marco de la política europea de
vecindad
pero que sin duda puede generar muchos
muchos cambios a nivel interno anime en
el nivel institucional pero también en
el nivel fundacional de la propia unión
europea hacia qué tipo de europa
queremos avanzar como la queremos
continuar
integrando si pasteur fundamentalmente
en términos de seguridad y despensa sí o
sí que o riesgo y realmente queremos
avanzar
en un proceso de integración que vaya
más allá de la seguridad nsa y lo
económico y también incorpore lo
político que es quizás lo más complicado
del plano y además que hay unos países
como usted lo menciona ruth por ejemplo
serbia bosnia herzegovina incluso
montenegro que llevan un proceso mucho
más avanzado sobre todo serbia ha estado
digamos ordenada haciendo su proceso de
incorporación como país candidato ha
avanzado en los temas de derechos
humanos y en los temas del pacto de
estabilización y ucrania está muy
atrasada todavía en en eso incluso otros
países como moldavia y georgia tienen
pasos más adelante que ucrania podría
entonces darse un estatus especial
podría ser una de las opciones dicen
algunos de los analistas también pero
eso cómo repercutiría entonces con moscú
jesús es una discusión muy interesante
que sin embargo digamos tenemos que
entender también que esta membresía es
algo que se vamos es decir se si puede
un acercamiento especial pueden un
proceso digamos muy rápido para generar
una declaración de candidatura oficial
pero de ahí en adelante el proceso es
muy muy largo en otras palabras digamos
en este momento primero tenemos que
sobrepasar una primera barrera y es
efectivamente el consejo europeo por
ejemplo tiene que ponerse de acuerdo y
eso ya de entrada es problemático porque
no todos los estados han estado en la
misma línea digamos de oposición directa
a vladimir putin si tenemos a los países
por ejemplo bálticos que tiene una
posición mucho más fuerte pero por otro
lado tenemos países como hungría que
tiene una posición mucho más suave de
alguna forma frente de frente de putin y
te toca mirar como efectivamente estas
posiciones afectan la toma de decisión
el consejo europeo y hasta qué punto
ucrania tiene la capacidad de sobrepasar
esas barreras pero fuera de eso tal como
lo menciona hay que es digamos cumplir
con ciertos criterios para poder hacer
parte de esa unión europea y ahí es
donde el proceso puede demorarse
muchísimo y creo que digamos a pesar de
que hay unas promesas y unas intenciones
muy claras la posibilidad de que ucrania
entre de manera expresa la unión europea
eso es exactamente es altamente difícil
me parece muy poco viable en esta xi y
la reacción de moscú
al recibir al recibir esta especie de
estatus especial o por lo menos este
acercamiento o un avance digamos en esa
negociación que bruselas moscú cómo
podría reaccionar es una buena pregunta
pero la verdad es que la unión europea
no es un alianza militar no de por sí
digamos ha buscado posicionarse primero
como un acuerdo de base económica
obviamente con objetivos políticos pero
de base económica y la parte de política
exterior es podría ser política de
seguridad y defensa ha estado un poco
digamos detrás de este proceso de
creación económica así que yo creo que
digamos la respuesta de putin no será la
misma que ver a ucrania tratando entre
la umh europea que sí es una mención
militar por supuesto a la otan declaró
la obtención de la otan y sobre todo de
nuevo reconociendo que el estatus de la
unió europea digamos se buscaba demorar
me parece que la respuesta obviamente no
será la misma que la que se tuvo con
anthony aproximándose al auto pero
entonces vemos escenarios como por
ejemplo la la reducción del envío de gas
de esta semana por parte de gas programa
europa puede ser el tipo de respuestas y
haga al grammy es una coincidencia muy
curiosa que el canciller alemana esté
visitando kiev y de repente haya fallas
técnicas en el norte y efectivamente se
reduzca en 40 por ciento casi el indio
gas a través de de celar es parte de la
estrategia rusa en cierta en cierta
forma en route pasemos ahora al
escenario en donde está inmerso eeuu que
es esta colaboración militar envío de
recursos económicos envío de armas que
tanto más puede soportar eeuu estar
dando este apoyo a distancia a la otan
y también directamente a ucrania no se
agota un poco la las posibilidades de
este apoyo kiev washington como lo
entiende usted buenos me permite apuntar
algo a lo anterior está por supuesto
adelantarte tener en consideración que
parte del territorio de ucrania
realmente sería el candidato no a entrar
en la unión europea y entonces aquí no
se explicaría parte de la potencia al
reacción de rusia si rusia consigue
controlar todo el donbass las regiones
que considera no vara astilla
probablemente no tenga ningún tipo de
oposición clara en el plano de lo
político a que la parte más occidental
de ucrania se ponga en el proceso de
avanzar en relación con la unión europea
es decir lo que tanto decía vladimir
putin que temía que era esa aproximación
hacia posiciones óptimas pro
occidentales de ucrania
y quedaría preservado para aquella zona
que considera que es
parte de la nación histórica de la
nación histórica en relación con la
segunda pregunta que planteaba
la sociedad es el apoyo de las
sociedades occidentales
eeuu pero también el reino unido y los
países de la unión europea pueden
aguantar digamos en el envío tanto de
armas como de donación de dinero y de
apoyo a ucrania bueno pues lo estamos
viendo ya como empiezan a aparecer
pequeñas fallas que se van a ir
profundizando porque el crecimiento de
la inflación en la crisis económica que
van a empezar a aparecer cada vez más de
manera más evidente los ciudadanos y
ciudadanas de los países afectados van a
generar una serie de presiones sobre los
gobiernos
en estos países que probablemente hagan
en algún momento que se pongan que ponga
en cuestión hasta qué punto realmente
está en ucrania merece la pena
en relación con lo que las demandas de
sus propios ciudadanos y esto puede ser
algo muy peligroso
especialmente de cara a un potencial
ascenso o un mayor mejor dicto mayor
ascenso de de opciones políticas de
extrema derecha que reivindiquen
precisamente la vuelta al proteccionismo
a cuestiones más de más nacionalistas y
sobre todo que se salgan digamos desde
el mensaje y en el caso de eeuu juega un
papel fundamental esa potencial llegada
o vuelta de laron al trans ruth y yo le
añado un componente adicional al factor
económico al incremento de la inflación
el aumento de los precios y las
dificultades que van a tener los
estadounidenses en los próximos meses en
términos de los gastos y su bolsillo y
es las elecciones de medio término
esto empieza también a ser un as bajo la
manga para ciertos los sectores
políticos en washington como puede ser
manejada y la situación
efectivamente las elecciones de meterme
que tenemos en los próximos meses
también van a ser escenciales para para
ver un poco hacia dónde hacia dónde se
va posicionando tanto republicanos como
demócratas como las respectivas acciones
dentro de los dos grupos no veremos si
efectivamente
trabajan a de manera unísona como una
política de estado en relación con
ucrania comienza efectivamente a ver una
cierta una cierta aunque tártago y sobre
todo cierto repliegue digamos a
cuestiones más norteamericanas y de
además decir bueno que nos estamos
cuando realmente nosotros en europa
cuando nosotros un estrategia
estratégicamente nuestro punto caliente
es asia-pacífico y es ahí donde queremos
prestar realmente atención y por el
canal de estudio jesús opiniones a la
cumbre y la cumbre la cumbre de la otan
de madrid va a ser esencial también para
ver esos equilibrios y si la unión
europea es capaz de plantear un objetivo
estratégico propio frente al
norteamericano y haber que posicionando
a eeuu no también hay si opiniones por
este lado jesús la posición de eeuu y le
añado otro componente el reino unido que
también son estado utilizando un poco el
tema de ucrania para poner un poco de
cortina de humo con el partido si
efectivamente digamos primero la
posición de eeuu y digamos es uno de los
actores que más se ha comprometido en
apoyar cierto autrán ya no sólo con
recursos sino también con apoyo militar
directo decir armas a pesar del riesgo
por supuesto que eso generado a pesar de
las críticas que se han generado pero
por tu lado digamos ya vemos que la
situación económica de eeuu también
empiezan a tambalear cierto la reserva
federal de eeuu empieza a subir tasas de
interés para tratar de compensar una
inflación que empieza a asociarse con la
guerra en ucrania y cuando efectivamente
un golpe al bolsillo de los ciudadanos
efectivamente la posición del gobierno
puede variar entonces vamos a ver cómo
efectivamente el gobierno logra
justificar todavía su presencia en esta
guerra
ante ante un cambio tan significativo
digamos en la economía del país por otro
lado el reino unido creo que el
presidente marco también fue acusado un
poco de utilizar ciertos argumentos o la
guerra para desviar un poco la atención
de asuntos domésticos si a johnson le ha
servido bastante me parece el mismo
presidente ucraniano ha reconocido en
muchas oportunidades que johnson es el
primer ministro que más se necesita por
el compromiso que ha demostrado el reino
unido junto con eeuu digamos mucho más
directo que otros estados en europa con
con la guerra y finalmente con el apoyo
de ucrania
por otro lado efectivamente aunque hay
todavía una coherencia y una cohesión
entre los países miembros incluso de la
unión europea por apoyar a ucrania rusia
tiene a favor el tiempo no porque rusia
está jugando con la democracia europea
donde las personas tienen la posibilidad
de expresarse en elecciones directas y
donde pueden castigar a gobernantes
cuando algo no les gusta efectivamente
entramos cuando hay una crisis económica
eso pues puede ser utilizado a favor de
rusia en rusia eso no va a pasar vemos
cómo a pesar de las sanciones económicas
la política del presidente está el
presidente ruso no ha sido cuestionado
porque no puede ser cuestionado
y eso es una enorme ventaja así que
digamos esta cohesión depende mucho de
que tanto desde el punto vista político
se pueden mantener justamente un
argumento de una cohesión suficiente
para mantener ese compromiso con ucrania
y eso con este escenario que usted nos
explica esta cohesión y esta necesidad
de mantener unido al bloque europeo y
también bueno a los aliados occidentales
con ucrania pero ante demandas
domésticas ante reclamos domésticos
porque recordemos que también las
sociedades de europa de eeuu vienen un
poco resentidos por el tema de la
pandemia que las economías no despegan
del todo y podemos ver a occidente de
pronto dando un paso atrás en su
compromiso con ucrania ante los reclamos
locales es un riesgo y me parece que ya
vimos por ejemplo en los comentarios de
henry kissinger en davos hablando sobre
como ucrania debería buscar una salida
negociada reconociendo un poco lo que ha
perdido
vimos un poco la posición del presidente
francés también digamos que no fue la
misma donde presenté francés hablado de
una posible negociación posconflicto
donde el objetivo no es humillar a rusia
sino buscar la solución un poco más
equilibrada pero parece que vemos
digamos ya un discurso un poco más a
favor de una posible negociación de un
posible diálogo entre ucrania aunque
todavía manteniendo el apoyo militar
claro pero ya me parece que empiezan a
filtrarse algunos diálogos y algunos
comentarios de esa naturaleza que
demuestran un poco también que los
europeos son conscientes de que
finalmente el paso del tiempo no
favorece finalmente su potencial apoyo
al conflicto no claro
ruth desde su perspectiva hay espacio
todavía aquí entonces para la democracia
en democracia aún y de la diplomacia
para estos dos países sería la palabra
correcta en negociar moscú kiev sentados
negociando un posible fin del conflicto
y tal vez ucrania aceptando perder el
donbass que es una zona ampliamente
industrializada pero que en su mayoría
son
habitantes en rusoparlantes
bueno yo creo que no siempre tienen que
estar abierta la vía de la diplomacia
pero la el fin del alto el fuego que
declarará cuando [__] investida que
quiere declarar el alto porque hoy eso
va a pasar cuando considere que tiene el
territorio que él quiere tener
controlado y que le va a permitir llegar
a una mesa de negociación de alto el
fuego en garantías de que ese territorio
va a permanecer en sus manos eso por el
lado por el lado de rusia por el lado de
ucrania creo que es importante ver
cuáles han sido hasta hace muy pocas
semanas los criterios que consideraba
selenski y su equipo de gobierno los
criterios para declarar una victoria no
para ponerse a negociar y esos eran en
primer lugar la la vuelta a las
fronteras de medias con el día 24 de
febrero la devolución de crimea y le
ingresó a la unión europea
así líneas generales había alguna otra
una otra cuestión como excepción de los
crímenes de guerra y la reconstrucción
del país pero esos eran los criterios
según los que consideraba el ente que
tendría que dar en los países tendría
que darse una victoria de ucrania parece
que desde las posiciones occidentales
aliadas de ucrania en lo que estamos
viendo es que también ha habido cambios
en el modo en el marco discursivo en
relación con esta con esta cuestión
puesto que al principio todo se aúna y
van planteando el discurso de tenemos
que tiene que haber una derrota clara de
rusia que tiene que seguir apoyando
digamos en ucrania con armas y con
suministros y con dinero y este discurso
se ha ido suavizando y matizando a lo
largo que a la vez que se aumentaba él
aumentaba en el transcurso el transcurso
de la guerra
y ahora lo que estamos observando es que
ya incluso baiden en alguna en alguna
intervención empresa norteamericana
bueno pues planteaba la necesidad de
moderar algunas algunas de estas
cuestiones porque está claro que no va a
haber un gran vencedor en esta guerra no
va a haber una victoria clara sino que
vamos a ver unas tablas en las cuales
ambas partes van a tener que exceder
probablemente rusia queda en esa en esa
incorporación en ese acercamiento de
ucrania a la unión europea y ucrania va
a tener que ceder sin duda parte de su
territorio no parece muy viable la
vuelta a las fronteras de vías está del
24 de febrero y hay muchas opciones que
quedan sobre la mesa y mucha
especulación también desde moscú hay
unos sectores que dicen que una
posibilidad es dividir el país dejar una
digamos una suerte de ucrania oriental y
una ucrania occidental eso me recuerda
un poco como el caso de chipper que
finalmente fue el lado grecochipriota al
que terminó entrando a la unión europea
y queda la zona norte sin reconocimiento
internacional es una no solamente
reconocido por turquía a la deriva en
muchos sentidos me recuerda un poco ese
caso pero también hay otros que dicen
que simplemente sería ceder la zona del
donbass y esa parte de la costa del mar
de azov y ucrania el resto del país
podría mantenerse
unido y mantenerse como un país
independiente son muchas las opciones
que hay y si hay un cambio en el
discurso en kiev pero en donde uno no no
está roto y jesús un cambio en el
discurso es en moscú y lo digo porque ya
lo citaba en la introducción del
programa esas declaraciones del
canciller ruso en una entrevista dada a
la bbc en el que reiteraba que rusia no
ha invadido el territorio ucraniano y
que haber llegado allí con una operación
militar especial era la única forma de
llamar la atención de occidente para
hacerle ver que una incorporación de
ucrania a la otan era simplemente una
acción criminal y estoy citando al
canciller lávrov por este lado jesús
impresiones de estas declaraciones del
canciller y este discurso ruso que se
mantiene un rígido firme que es un
discurso es la continuación de alguna
forma de la posición que asumió putin
hace una semana más o menos cuando
digamos trataba de llenarse como una
especie de nuevo pedro el grande no
decir aquel actor que no trata de
quitarle territorio a otro sino trata de
recuperar lo que es de él y en ese mismo
contexto es evidente que se considera
que una parte de ucrania es rusa por
digamos tradición cultural histórica y
demás y por lo cual rusia tiene derecho
a recuperarlo así que efectivamente la
línea de lávrov en esa misma dirección
es si no hay ninguna operación especial
por invadir a alguien no hay ningún
esfuerzo por tratar de quitarlo alguien
quitarle algo a alguien si no puede
recuperar algo que le pertenece a rusia
y es un discurso de nuevo extremadamente
peligroso porque tal como ya se mencionó
en otros casos podría ser un precedente
para futuras expansiones rusas para más
adelante sus impresiones ruth sobre
estas declaraciones del canciller
también que tendrán lugar esta semana y
si un poco se mantiene en esa línea de
apelación al al esto esencialista de la
nación rusa de controlar aquellos
territorios en los que considera que hay
población en rusia que por lo tanto
como líderes tienen derecho a esa
protección
así que sí que creo que no hay cambios
sustantivos en el discurso que en el
discurso ruso se ha mantenido de manera
de manera firme desde el principio de la
guerra pero sí que es verdad que no es
cierto o mejor dicho no es cierto lo que
plantea lo que plantea el kremlin en
relación con que les era imposible que
les hiciera caso evidente en relación
con la reforma de la arquitectura de
seguridad europea puesto que ya en
diciembre incluso en enero la otan y
washington en particular les advierte
ido a abrir estas negociaciones incluso
la posibilidad de modificar algunas de
estas cuestiones que en ese momento
cuando decidió invadir el donbass por lo
tanto hay algo más misma la reforma de
la arquitectura de seguridad detrás de
esto y probablemente en eso esas esas
ínfulas imperiales que caracterizan a a
vladimir putin no sé si usted les da la
impresión jesús ruth que a lo largo de
estas dos últimas semanas putin ha
estado un poco más ausente de los medios
tanto rusos como internacionales está
delegando un poco más el manejo de este
tema
la cancillería rusa ya su portavoz el
portavoz del kremlin más que el salir en
los medios parte de alguna estrategia o
tratará de estar a tratando de limpiar
un poco su imagen o despegarse un poco
de lo que ha sucedido como lo ve usted
root
bueno yo creo que
es un poco aleatorio también está
escuchando esta semana declaraciones de
media vez diciendo que ucrania
desaparecería o no volvería a ser la
misma que antes del 24 de febrero es
decir tiene al igual que las
cancillerías occidentales el crimen
también tiene su propiedad como todos
sabemos su propia mecanismos de
propaganda y de comunicación política y
bueno en este caso pues nos dan no sé yo
no sé quién pueda saber qué es lo que
está haciendo por lo que está pasando
por la cabeza ahora mismo pero
probablemente bueno pues se esté dando
por hecho que la cronificación del
conflicto está asegurada y que por tanto
dejar pasar el tiempo y no exponerse a
en los medios de comunicación es una
garantía también de bueno no tener que
rendir cuentas si en el caso de su
propiedad de su propia población la
estrategia que está siguiendo rusia es
esa cronificación de la guerra porque
sabe que ellos son capaces de aguantar
mucho más
en los países occidentales
si alguien decía que alguien decía que
los rusos tienen mucha más capacidad de
resistencia y aguantan mucho más el
hambre que los europeos las carestías
sin más que una capacidad militar en
jesús y también lo que uno no está a lo
largo de estas semanas la dificultad
para las tropas rusas para poder
recuperar el terreno en severo dodgers
que llevamos 23 semanas con
enfrentamientos muy fuertes allí
dificultades para sacar a los civiles
que están allí a través de los canales
humanitarios que han sido habilitados y
tal vez da la impresión por lo menos de
este lado del mundo que las tropas
ucranianas les está costando un poco más
mantenerse en la zona del frente y han
tenido que retroceder y bueno ahí hay un
rifirrafe en posición si efectivamente
eso deseen buena parte al cambio
estrategia en ciertos de abril digamos
cuando cuando rusia se retiró de la
región de quien se demostró digamos un
cambio y lo que se intentó fue tratar de
centrarse mucho más digamos objetivos
mucho más específicos y no tan generales
y eso ha permitido concentrar esfuerzos
en objetivos concretos entonces ver de
unidades que es un ejemplo de ello y eso
hace que obviamente le cueste muchísimo
más mantener terreno pero por tu lado
rosetti una enorme ventaja en artillería
eso ya se ha discutido es decir tiene la
capacidad de destruir completamente
cualquier forma de resistencia física
a la cual ucrania lamentablemente no
tiene cómo responder por ahora por eso
si insiste en que le den que porten
armas un poco más pesadas nueva
artillería y sistemas de misiles pero
digamos rusia tiene la ventaja en ese
contexto y por otro lado en cuanto a
civiles digamos el gran problema es que
rusia ha ofrecido la creación de
corredores humanitarios es cierto pero
que llevan al territorio controlado por
usos y de ahí los civiles pasan por
campos de filtración es decir digamos un
sistema de control para evitar que
aquellos que rusia considera que son
peligrosos puedan volver a ucrania y eso
entonces no es una opción muy clara por
los ciudadanos ucranianos que temen
justamente no poder volver a
eventualmente su propio territorio su
propio casco también fue destacado esta
semana un informe de inteligencia fueron
publicados en diferentes medios
internacionales
una suerte de rumor de una investigación
que decía que en los próximos 12 días
moscú podría estar dando inicio a una
operación militar a gran escala para
empezar a pensar
kiev pero si uno ve las posiciones rusas
en este momento que está muy lejos de
donde están las tropas rusas incluso de
esa primera entrada de soldados desde el
norte procedente de belarús esa zona ya
fue recuperada por ucrania vemos que
también están reconstruyendo algunos de
los suburbios alrededor de kiev
es factible esto en términos tácticos
kiev estaría próxima a ser el objetivo
después de ver a daniels y tiene razón
digamos geográficamente se ve muy lejos
personalmente pensaría que no pero de
nuevo no pensáramos que no pensábamos en
finales de animación que iba a haber una
versión que con qué pasará directamente
desde desde una planta nuclear destruida
que es un riesgo para la humanidad
básicamente y tratar del gara que yo
personalmente creo que no creo que hay
muchas más preocupaciones por controlar
gerson digamos la parte de
la parte de la costa exactamente y sobre
todo porque de gerzón depende por
supuesto del suministro de agua potable
a crimea así que uno pensaría que de
alguna forma hay más más objetivos mucho
más importantes para rusia en este
momento sin embargo nuevo no podemos
entrar directamente a la cabeza de putin
y claro en ese contexto digamos
finalmente podría pasar cualquier cosa y
esperemos que también veíamos hace unos
días que las tropas ucranianas
recuperaba en ciertos sectores en
jarquín y los últimos reportes
dan cuenta de una cruenta batalla otra
vez en esta ciudad que la segunda ciudad
más grande más poblada de ucrania ya me
quedan pocos minutos para finalizar el
programa route jesús y quiero que
hagamos conclusiones siempre lo digo no
tenemos la bola de cristal - en este
tema que cada semana suceden cosas
diferentes y nos toca abordarlo desde
diferentes puntos de vista pero qué
puede pasar en los próximos días más
movimientos militares un poco más de
diplomacia por parte de la unión europea
ucrania tratando de mantenerse en el
severo 10 qué impresiones puede haber de
cara a las próximas semanas ruth
bueno yo creo que
en exit en relación con el teatro
operaciones en el terreno yo creo que la
situación se va a mantener más o menos
como hasta ahora no se ve que se vayan a
abrir nuevos frentes quizás como decían
el compañero
y sobre todo asegurar la zona de persona
la zona del sur más que un ataque hacia
que parecería más probable no y más
factible que si intentas avanzar y out
esa pero tampoco hemos visto grandes
intenciones militares en ese en ese
sentido y a partir de ahí yo creo que va
a ser muy importante dos fechas una la
semana que viene lo que decidan europeo
y la otra es una reunión de la otan de
madrid de finales de junio en la cual se
va a debatir este nuevo objetivo
estratégico y en la cual vamos a ver
efectivamente cuáles van a ser las
decisiones que adopten las potencias
occidentales aliadas en relación con la
ayuda que van a prestar a ucrania y dos
cuál quiere ser la determinación en
relación con rusia si efectivamente
quieren ir a la alineación verdad tengo
que darle tiempo a gestos para que hagan
su conclusión simplemente muy bien algo
muy corto efectivamente digamos en
cuanto al aspecto militar el único
cambio pues y podría darse es si
efectivamente las armas prometidas
largas empiezan a llegar y empiezan a
llegar en masa con digamos el apoyo
necesario pero es poco probable digamos
a corto plazo desde el punto de vista
político es importante que las
demostraciones de apoyo se sigan
manteniendo lo que creo que hicieron los
líderes de francia alemania rumanía y
por supuesto italia debe seguirse dando
no sólo discursos sino también con
hechos y eso va a garantizar de una
forma que ucrania se siente apoyada y
que siga recibiendo la ayuda que
necesita para mantenerse pues arrodilla
jesús les agradezco mucho por haber
estado con nosotros haber hecho este
análisis para la audiencia de france 24
en américa latina' ustedes pueden seguir
dejando sus comentarios y sus preguntas
a través de las redes sociales sigan con
nosotros
[Música]